quoique si nous devons j'aurais tous ici
johnny mathis et je vous souhaite la
bienvenue à kapatakan cette semaine dans
mon portable j'avais envie de discuter
avec vous d'un événement en fait qui
m'est arrivé dernièrement puis que
susciter une certaine réflexion pour moi
au niveau de la notion d'appropriation
qui d'appréciation culturel en fait il
ya quelques semaines j'étais dans un
restaurant de québec donc un restaurant
autochtone à québec avec un groupe
d'amis autochtone et il ya un moment
dans la soirée ou est ce qu il ya les
serveurs qui sont arrivés pour célébrer
l'anniversaire d'un client
avec un temps beau donc on arrive avec
le gâteau le petit feu de bengale et on
arrive aussi avec avec un tambour et on
joue du tambour pour célébrer
l'anniversaire
est
vraiment ma table ça de susciter un
certain
un certain malaise dans un sens parce
qu'il faut savoir on était
essentiellement que des usines où et en
tout cas dans la culture et nous le thé
week-end le tambour a une signification
particulière c'est un c'est un
instrument qu'on sort pas au quotidien
c'est un instrument concentre surtout
dans des moments spéciaux dans des
cérémonies pour pour souligner quelque
chose puis pour nous le de sortir un
objet qui est un peu une signification
sacré comme celle du thé wiggles pour
célébrer l'anniversaire de
de ginette cinquante trois ans avec un
petit cadeau cheap avec un feu de
bengale ben ça nous a remis mardi
c'est arrivé une deuxième fois dans la
soirée puis encore à ce moment là on a
vu la réflexion sur comment est-ce qu'on
sent par rapport à ça et en fait cet
événement le fn m en moins certain
questionnement par rapport à est ce que
nous en tant qu'autochtones on peut se
permettre de prendre des éléments de nos
cultures des éléments culturels et il ya
un peu de pour moi une certaine forme de
perversion là dedans donc de les
utiliser
comme on veut dans le contexte où on
veut sous seul prétexte que c'est un
élément culturel autochtone et qu'on y
est autochtone et qu'on a le droit de le
faire à cause qu'on est autochtone et
dans ma tête en fait à quelque part
c'est la réponse c'est non en fait au
départ pour - il la première question
c'est qu'il faut comprendre nos cultures
il faut savoir d'où les éléments
viennent puis
de mon point de vue le camp contente de
culture autochtone il faut en parler au
pluriel parce qu'on dit lever plusieurs
réalités autochtones mais il ya
également plusieurs cultures autochtones
et les différences d'une nation est une
autre des fois d'un événement d'une
communauté à une autre au sein d'une
même nation puis pour moi en scandant
maquette
culturelle identitaire
je me pose beaucoup ces questions là en
fait je me demandais ce que ces éléments
là ils sont propres à ma nation est ce
qu'ils sont proprement premières nations
et de quelle façon est ce que est ce que
je me réapproprie dans un sens ces
éléments là est ce que c'est vraiment le
reflet de ma culture je pense que ça
c'est le premier élément je pense que
nous en tant qu'autochtones puis je vais
vraiment parler pour moi
pour ma réalité dans ce qui me concerne
moins pendant quelques années mais j'ai
peut-être eu moins un contact facile
envers ma culture mais j'ai surtout est
exposé à la culture on va dire général
des autochtones
on voit pas une denrée film ou ou des
éléments qui sont peut-être lié au
folklore mais aujourd'hui dans mon
processus personnel de réappropriation
culturelle mais je me pose beaucoup de
questions de est ce que les éléments que
je vois et auxquels je me suis peut-être
identifier un certain moment sont
vraiment des éléments qui concerne ma
propre culture et je pense que ça c'est
la première étape à faire puis ensuite
la deuxième question qui me vient en
tête c'est est-ce que je peux prendre
ces éléments de ma culture de mes
cultures et les utiliser la façon que je
veux en fait c'est pour pour moi j'ai
vraiment une forme de perversion de la
culture après il ya beaucoup cet élément
de culture spectacle on va dire
clairement l'établissement où ce qu'on
était
fait ça pour faire plaisir à ses clients
un joli clin ism selon son vote en
bourse et c'est très typé le qui ont
fréquentent ces établissements le parce
qu'on aime ce côté typique à la
réflexion que j'ai c'est nous en tant
qu'autochtones
est-ce qu'on dispose de nos cultures de
la bonne façon et ce qu'on les met en
valeur de la bonne façon je pense que
souvent oui dans certains cas non et je
pense que c'est à ce moment là qu'on
doit se questionner on doit se
questionner à savoir est ce que est ce
que parce que je mets ma culture
correctement en valeur en faisant cette
chose-là puis de l'autre côté mais je
pense que les gens qui reçoivent ça
doivent aussi se poser la question parce
que si on fait sont perverties en plus
nos futurs comme ça parce qu'on les met
en valeur de cette façon là c'est un peu
parce que les gens de nom donc je pense
que de l'autre côté il ya aussi une
réflexion à avoir par rapport à quel
type de culture je souhaite consommer
est ce que je souhaite consommer quelque
chose qui kim en met plein les yeux puis
qu'il fallait dire waouh depuis qui me
confortent dans l'image que j'ai des
autochtones en voiture peut-être un peu
stéréotypé où est ce que je cherche
vraiment une expérience authentique où
est-ce qu'on expose les éléments
culturels au pied
quelqu'un que je consomme que ce soit un
champ tambour que ce soit de l'artisanat
que ce soit dollar je pense que c'est
important de que ces éléments le soin
mis en contexte pour dans un sens
éveillés les gens à nos cultures puis
qu'ils les comprennent davantage
je pense qu'en faisant soudain on fait
un pas de plus dans la réconciliation
parce qu'on s'envoie dans une culture
qui est vrai une culture qui est
authentique et je pense que je pense que
c'est l'objectif qu'on devrait viser
ensemble donc c'est un peu les éléments
que je souhaitais vous partager
aujourd'hui je suis curieux de voir
peut-être que les gens pensent comment
vous positionner par rapport à ça et sur
ce je vous souhaite une excellente
réflexion et j'espère que vous avez aimé
cette capsule